So now we will go through several
types of multiprocessors.
The first type of multiprocessor
uses what is called a centralized
shared memory.
So all the cores, let's say we have 4
of them, might have their own caches,
but then they're all
connected to the same bus, so
they can all access the same main
memory and input output devices.
These cores can share data by simply
reading and writing the main memory,
assuming of course that these reads and
writes go through the caches properly,
and we will see that we can
achieve that, so pretty much,
this core can send data to this core
by writing to some memory location,
and then this core reads it from there.
Similarly, any of the cores can
access any of the other devices here.
This type of a system is
really what today's multi-core
processors tend to look like,
and it's also called UMA,
which stands for
uniform memory access time.
But it's not UMAT, it's just UMA.
But what is uniform is really
the time to access the memory.
Why?
Well, because this main memory
is at the same long distance
from all of the cores.
Yes, it can be slightly
closer to some of them.
But because they are all
connected to it in the same way,
the memory really is about as bad
to access as any one of them.
This time of multiprocessing
is also called SMP,
which stands for
Symmetric Multiprocessor.
It's called symmetric
because any core and
its cache look just like any other
core and its cache in the system.
So if we have two cores, we can just
take one of them with its caches and
replicate to make a four-core system.